[Musique]
être
parce qu'ils ne sont pas noirs pourquoi le ciel
bleu euh non
pas vraiment je n'en ai aucune idée
je ne suis pas sûr peut-être que ça les rend plus
visibles surtout la nuit pour être
différent des
voitures normales il y avait une université d'étude
jaune
[  Musique]
[Musique]
question de test où se trouve Times Square 42e
et 42e rue
[Musique]
je pense que c'est très intéressant beaucoup de gens en
ont beaucoup en tant que patients beaucoup d'entre
eux ont des doctorats de leur pays
conduite imprudente pas très polie
d'excellents chauffeurs et très magnifiques oui, ils
savent où tout se trouve,
leurs compétences de conduite sont incroyables
et ils sont
très ils ont de bonnes personnalités
fous ils vont
bien mais ils ne sont pas américains
américains
seulement
à new york